my name's bamm-bamm is muwah from
Division my organization is enhanced by
the satellite defense I'm in this
conference is very much interested in
the issue of security a specific
security of food which beautiful party
to me is which security is a very civil
sample that makes a lot of people
standing uncomfortably become poor
people because of the factor asian of
put ability with availability and also
because of here are less government our
commitment policy before hundred tons of
development I think it's a lot of
opportunity catering to surface problem
there are some power not necessarily
change paradigms but to intensify the
existing paradigm for example how to our
minimize or food I pacifies put my local
food available can you reach a reason a
lot of what local food that are good for
people and if the information of has
work I've put consumption advice and it
is a very high because every individuals
afflicted consume 130 kilogram price
actually it is a much higher than at
least worth if we can minimize become
every sniper countries then we can
produce about thirty percent and this
can be reduced because haha
and more consistently developed from a
policy implication for food technical
education this is this is 11 point so if
you can forget what is the same power
consumption pattern we can't refuse the
number of food consumption in vice versa
in exactly that was some flowers
relative to his roof provided by our
system meal of rice intensification and
this is before it city has online is a
very handsome introduced at the local
level and if you can expand in a very
good Muslim systematic approach side
then travel in turn increase production
charge fifty percent so decreasing our
consumption size thirty percent and
increasing production five fifty percent
are they in traditionally not to worry
because they're but with one two
missions that we can make it as a kind
of movement of the people government and
protons are blanket second combatant in
all the caliper piston